Харківщина б'є антирекорди за кількістю нових хворих на коронавірус.
За смертністю область теж серед антилідерів -
разом з Києвом, Дніпровщиною і Львівщиною. 11 квітня Харків
офіційно оголосили "червоною" зоною. Але в дійсності місто стало "червоним"
набагато раніше. Виходячи з дописів лікарів у соцмережах
та розповідей родичів хворих, ситуація з "ковідом" у місті
різко погіршилася ще кілька тижнів тому.
Лікарні відмовляються приймати хворих через відсутність вільних ліжок.
Реанімаційні процедури пацієнтам у домашніх умовах проводили лікарі швидкої.
Приїжджала швидка, підключали до апарату дихання,
тому що просто задихалася мама.
Дзвонили в усі лікарні, дізнавалися, де є вільні ліжка.
Місць не було - ніяких і ніде. Ні в коридорі, ніде…
Олена Мельнікова чекала на госпіталізацію матері
з сатурацією 66 два дні, сама придбала кисневий концентратор,
шукала медсестр для крапельниць.
Врешті місце знайшлося лише в цьому госпіталі для ветеранів,
де нещодавно відкрили нове "ковідне" відділення. Як тільки
воно з'явилося, швидкі миттєво почали звозити сюди
хворих, збираючи одразу по кілька пацієнтів в одну машину.
Я відправила маму на швидкій. Мене не взяли, тому що
не було місць для інших хворих. У швидкій є кілька кисневих масок,
які дозволяють підтримувати хворих у стабільному стані.
Ось вони й об’їжджають райони Харкова і навіть передмістя,
збирають хворих і привозять сюди.
80 ліжок у цьому відділені заповнили хворими за лічені години.
Ситуація критична, скаржаться лікарі швидких.
"КОвідних" бригад для порятунку хворих уже не вистачає.
Ми не "ковідна" бригада, ми випадково потрапили.
У нас була дуже важка хвора з низькою сатурацією 70,
з низькими показниками артеріального тиску і загального стану.
Враховуючи, що важкий стан, в неї була пневмонія,
зробили тест, і тест позитивний.
Останнім часом у Харкові щодня фіксували 800 нових хворих.
І це лише за офіційними даними. Днями цей показник перевалив за тисячу.
Загалом у Харкові п’ять лікарень приймають коронавірусних хворих,
це приблизно 840 ліжок. Усі ці медзаклади вже місяць як переповнені.
У нас було розраховано на 180 ліжок.
Але на сьогодні в нас хворих з підтвердженим "ковідом" - 283 людини.
Ми доставляємо додаткові ліжка в палати. Там, де було три ліжка -
тепер чотири, там, де було шість - сім-вісім.  Якщо потрібно
надавати допомогу хворому, якого привезли до приймального
відділення, на жаль, ми ставимо ліжка і в коридорах.
Більшість ліків для лікування коронавірусу за протоколом МОЗ
у харківських лікарнях є. Однак немає головних противірусних препаратів -
ремдесивіру і актерми. Їх теж мала б закуповувати держава, але постачання
нестабільне. На чорному ринку ці препарати є, і родичі платять
за ліки по кілька сотень доларів. Однак часто дорогоцінний час
вже втрачено. Щотижня у Харкові від коронавірусу помирає 50 хворих.
Мої співчуття. Сталося серцево-судинне.  Тобто, так,
зупинилося серце. Вчора стан погіршився.
Йому підключили препарати, які піднімають тиск,
максимальні дози. Але дива не сталося.
Руслан Врагов завідує "ковідним" відділенням
в 17-тій харківській лікарні з червня.
На 60-ти ліжках лежать 82 пацієнти.
Наразі вільних місцьу реанімації немає.
Кому потрібна реанімація, минамагаємося їх сюди переводити.
Місця для нових пацієнтів звільняються не швидко.
З березня хвороба має більш затяжний перебіг.
На Харківщину зайшли нові штами вірусу,
кажуть лікарі. Дедалі більше пацієнтів 30+.
Пацієнт іноді поступає до нас із КТ, на якому 5-10%
ураження легень, а за два-три дні
в нього тотальнеураження легень.
Якщо ще наприкінці минулого року "ковідний" пацієнт у середньому
проводив у лікарні 7-10 днів, то тепер це 14, а то і 3-4 тижні.
Було лячно, тому що цей новий "ковід" дає таку задуху,
що перетворюєшся на стару людину, не можеш піднятися сходами.
З того, що я тут бачу, поточна кількість хворих велика.
Постійно надходять нові, в доволі важкому стані.
З легкою формою тут немає.
Більшість тяжких пацієнтів потребують кисневих точок.
Якщо ці місця зайняті, лікарня не може прийняти пацієнта.
Наразі мерія додатково оснащує кисневими трасами три харківські лікарні.
Через бюрократію роботи затягуються. Проблема також
у відсутності кисневих бочок.
Ми не можемо відкрити відділення у 18-ій лікарні.
Там є 60 ліжок, там уже проведено кисень до кожного ліжка.
Але ми не можемо відкрити це відділення,
тому що для відкриття нам потрібна ємність
з високопоточним киснем. Як тільки ми знайдемо
кисневу бочку і встановимо,  проблема буде знята.
З березня хворих з Харкова почали доправляти  до лікарень області,
адже тут, як запевняє вдала, створено майже п’ять тисяч ліжкомісць.
Однак ліжок з високопоточним киснем насправді лише третина.
Є 4900 ліжок. Вони усі забезпечені киснем.
Використовується з визначеної госпітальної бази 3350 ліжок.
Вони так само визначені як ліжка, забезпечені киснем.
З них майже 1150 з потоковим киснем.
Інші забезпечені концентраторами. Хвороба зараз підступна,
вона в третю хвилю більш агресивна. Пацієнти потрапляють
у більш важкому стані, і сьогодні  недостатньо концентраторів,
які є в наявності. Місцева влада згаяла час ще влітку,
коли слід було ретельніше підготуватися до нових спалахів пандемії,
і дуже повільно реагує на актуальні виклики. Від місцевих волонтерів
та депутатів постійно чутно багато критики на адресу чиновників.
Не використали час. Частину коштів на боротьбу з коронавірусом
повернули, не була освоєна. Було багато провалів,
не були проведені кисневі траси своєчасно.
Частина кисневих трас прокладалася не державою,
а за рахунок волонтерів, коштів бізнесу.
Це наслідок того, що або не вміють,
або не приділили достатньо уваги, на жаль…
На думку депутата, в регіоні слід було запроваджувати локдаун
ще кілька тижнів тому і заборонити масові заходи під час масниці.
У мерії й облдержадміністрації з цим не згодні.
Кажуть, що рівень захворюваності підскочив лише нещодавно,
мовляв, чиновники роблять усе можливе. І вказують на ще
одну серйозну проблему.
За минулий рік ми втратили 2000 медпрацівників.
Автобус на Польщу кожен день їздить. Біля кожного ліжка
повинен працювати лікар та медсестри.
Ми сьогодні повністю вичерпали професійний ресурс.
Ми закликаємо усіх, ми просимо студентів,
які мають дипломи фельдшерів і середня медична освіта,
усіх, хто тільки зможе працювати…
Однак проблема нестачі кваліфікованого медперсоналу
далі залишається дуже гострою.
Тобто в нас просто настане такий час, що по-іншому нічого не буде…
Можливо, це буде  мобілізація медпрацівників.
Це як вихід. Я бачу залучення формувань
цивільного захисту, військових, медформувань Нацгвардії.
По-іншому, навряд чи…
В облдержадміністрації не виключають, що доведеться, як у Західній Україні,
розгортати мобільні шпиталі. Адже пік захворюваності в області
ще не минув. Місто чекає на нову партію вакцини.
Щепитися першою дозою досі зголосилися лише
менше трьох з половиною тисяч харків’ян.